♪ Kodachrome ♪
♪ Give us those nice bright colors ♪
♪ Give us the greens of summer ♪
♪ Makes you think all the
world is a summer day, oh my ♪
- [Mark] You're a great singer.
- Oh, yeah.
- [Mark] So, Evelyn.
- [Evelyn] Yeah?
- [Mark] So I found you again
on the street here in Tenderloin.
Here in San Francisco.
- [Evelyn] Yeah.
- [Mark] What was that you
were smoking when I found you?
- What drew me here, that's cocaine.
It's for teaching illiterate mothers
how to handle an obnoxious situation.
- [Mark] I'll bet it is.
- The oblong boy wearing
jewelry on his chest
that looks like a knife when
he picks up his sick cigarette.
The refusion of alcohol,
the red hairs pubing.
Those are called pubes,
they itch all the time.
You have to take a really rough surface,
even a rock from a lava
or two crushed cubes.
Not that light thing that
the black boys play with.
They like to teach white girls
how to take cigarette boxes
and pull them apart and that
pulls 'em into their football.
And so I scratch my pubes
with toilet paper cleaner
and I call it a toothbrush
because my face is so
white it looks like water.
When I left Vigo, I left a puddle behind,
and I was with my father-in-law.
My mother said, "You can't
get married because,"
and she sniffed a lot
and her back lit on fire.
Then I gave her a foot-washing
and I lay my hands in the cool water,
and I saw someone drowning in a pool,
and I pulled him up by his dick.
And I said, "Dick Tracy,"
and he went to New York
and stayed in New Jersey.
New Jersey is the floodway
of the New York Hudson River.
It has so much pollution
that children are backlogged
up to 30 years for getting
their test results.
And I said, "Don't say bath."
And I saw my spine in pre-elementary.
That's before you've gone outside.
You're held like a fat piece of chicken,
and when they see you going outside
and the red doors are open,
those are bar-burners,
that means you're gonna need a
drink in about three minutes,
and we didn't get one and we
turned into the 1922 Dust Bowl,
and we were given sanctuary by Wild Rock.
That's also people who know
that they can't get a drink.
- [Mark] Evelyn?
- Yeah?
- [Mark] Is there anyone that takes
care of you here in the street?
Are there any of the
homeless organizations
that are here helping people,
or you have no family, I
assume, that's helping you?
No one's helping you?
- Well-
- [Mark] You don't have
a tent still, right?
- The marathoners help me the most.
People running in
shorts, going over brick,
stopping in Irish or Swedish bars.
- [Mark] Where do you go to eat?
- I don't eat, I make food,
and then if it returns to
me, I'll think of my bike
and I'll put the brakes on,
and I'll lay the food down,
then if I see Mexican jumping
beans, I will eat them,
and tacos, I could gobble up the world.
But the word helter-skelter came to me
and I was hit in the back of my noggin
with a baseball bat when I feasted
on those black guys' toes.
So I know they've held the bat.
Why, this is a funny one.
A man walks down the street
with a short little attention span.
You can call me Ally,
you can call me Betty,
and that makes cake.
♪ Someone left a cake out in the rain ♪
♪ I don't think that I can take it ♪
♪ 'Cause it took so long to make it ♪
♪ And I'll never have
this recipe again, again ♪
♪ Someone left a cake out in the rain ♪
♪ I don't think that I can take it ♪
♪ A rain took so long to bake it ♪
♪ And I'll never have
this recipe again, again ♪
- [Mark] You're amazing, Evelyn.
- Aw, thank you.
- [Mark] You're so interesting.
- [Mark] Are you happy?
- Yeah, when I look at equipment.
When something's going on, then I am,
but when people stop
or they take their leather out on the road
and kick it to death, you know,
making those little blondes
with the scrawny arms
that are spilling the milkshake and fries.
Mexicans don't get much to eat.
They rely on ocean beach survivors.
I like to think when I swam
that it was 11 people maybe even doing it.
But, you know, you get so
blinded by the harsh conditions.
17 years of rain in one
backyard, your kids washed away.
Coming in stomping on
your trousers, you know.
- [Mark] You ever get depressed?
Living on the street like this.
- 17 years ago, I was.
I thought I was gonna be the
only one living on the earth,
and I said, "I repent," and
the van was waiting for me,
and they dropped me off at a national park
and they were cooking
burgers, people were waiting.
I said, "Just grab one," and they did,
and somebody's cigarette got lit by it,
and another guy's went out.
And I said, "Boy, this is the saddest
creation I've ever seen,
we've got to fan out."
So they took me back to this
emporium, I'll call it now,
now that I know Money Mart.
And I was reliving my days of
eating and the van drove off.
I had to walk into San Jose.
- [Mark] Evelyn, what was your
favorite memory in your life?
- Being at T.S. Eliot's opening
of Jerry Seinfeld's "Why
The Devil Ate My Baby."
I said, "That's an early
name for chocolate,"
and I immediately got home,
the state's had released me.
I said, "It's not new information,"
and again I was taken.
I was on top of the ski board,
and I had to dive in to
get television back on.
And again I was in the national park
and I had to walk out on a dirt road,
and I met some people and
they gave me a granola bar
and I didn't lay it down,
I had to walk for 71 days.
And when I got home, there
was a little store there,
and people were hitting each other.
And they grabbed me by
the back of the hair,
and I said, "All right, I'll
lay down the granola bar."
And I did and a black
woman came over for me
and she took my pipe and she
smashed it to the ground,
so I went on a worldwide search,
and I ended up in front of a taco shack,
and I didn't order a
taco, I knew I didn't have
the funds to pay for it,
being without a pipe.
(Evelyn puffing)
And I said, "Are you the Mexican?"
I said, "How do you make it last?"
I said, "These paper plates are clogged,
she must be here at three in the morning."
And she said, "I am," and
she wiped a tear like this.
I said, "You just said fuck yourself."
I said, "I'm gonna take my shoes off
and leave them for you,"
and I walked back to the office
and I found a pair of shoes.
And I was behind the fence
and the officers came up
and I said,
♪ So I creep, creep ♪
♪ I just creep around without you ♪
♪ I just creep until I'm feeling fine ♪
And we walked all over
that neighborhood together.
And I laid down a lipstick.
I was tired of them,
they're paranoid, you know.
They get kicked in the ass so hard.
I mean, baseball is like
a killing field.
And I was playing the
game, I remember that game.
She still won't come home.
And I said that, and I
was behind Whole Foods.
And I said, "I wonder if people are still
eating that dried bread
that makes the beds creak."
And I said, "You need
some grease in there?"
And I looked up and there
was a full portrait.
Whole Foods with a circle
about seven to 12 inches long,
and the generator was closed.
- [Mark] Evelyn, what-
- Yeah?
What's my worst memory,
I'll fill in for ya.
- [Mark] Thank you.
- Being on a sex date.
Being trapped by automatic machines.
Seeing people follow me and
not knowing what to say.
I said, "If you had said stalker,
you would've startled that street
and they would've followed her."
I said, "I'd like them to follow me."
And I was in a castle,
and these are people
who forget their life.
So I said,
♪ One fine day ♪
(Evelyn puffing)
And I saw a penny laying on the ground,
and I knew it was emergency equipment.
And I said this really
loud boisterous name.
I said, "I've gotta call you something."
I said, "These dinners that
these nurses are getting
are making 17-foot doors."
I said, "I've been down to the office."
He said, "Oh, the office?"
He said, "Oh, I've got,"
and he handed me a $20 bill.
And I started crying right away,
and I knew it was the
front of the church doors.
(Evelyn puffing)
So I said, "The poetry man,"
then I said, "Angrily,
they stomped about."
And I said, "Jesus, I've
seen you all my life.
I just had a little rabbit
coat to start out with.
If you want me, you can think of bowling."
And I was in Bowling Green, Kentucky
just waiting to become a naval audiocraft.
I thought they knew sound waves.
And I got some fame that day,
and it sickened my legs.
I was in a tanker up in Alaska.
- [Mark] Evelyn?
- [Evelyn] Yeah?
- [Mark] How long you been smoking crack?
- [Evelyn] For 61 years.
- [Mark] How old are you?
- [Evelyn] 61.
- [Mark] You started early.
- Yeah.
Well, I needed something to
recover those banana tables.
We were having luaus in Hawaii.
The men would jump off cliffs,
thinking it was a blue-eyed girl.
I baked so many muffins
that day, 24 rounds,
and then I got here to San Francisco
and I found out that the chocolate chip
outsold the blueberries.
(Evelyn puffing)
I see a man,
and I said, "I'm addicted to paper."
I'm reading so much
that my retina detaches.
And the ambulance says, "We
have your hip replacement."
I said, "I've done this two times.
You've already told me that I
get up and get out too much."
I said, "All I want is a drink of water."
And they put men's balls in a little bowl,
and I say, "Honey."
This tank that I rolled up
in, I sailed north to Alaska.
I said, "That dog is so broken down,"
and I said, "Mama handed me money,
but I know it's just a little notebook."
I said, "When my son and I
died in each other's arms,
I became a black woman,
but I didn't eat ice cream,
and I only ate two of them,
so I know I sometimes that
when I think of marshmallows.
And I said, "Those are brakes,"
and I wanted to dance so bad
that I said, "St. Anthony's."
And I wanted a milk and he
wouldn't let me pick it up,
so I said, "Well, if
I can't strip for you,
then you can have my saggy tits."
And he started stirring around
and I said, "When I get dreadlocks,"
and he picks up my beer.
(Evelyn puffing)
That was on a large island.
Children are not wanted on islands.
They're heavy drifters, they
don't like trains either.
They use towels, they smack
blondes on the behind,
and I had a scene with Don Ho
and she wouldn't let me kiss him.
And I said, "Now I don't have any love."
She said, "We have been on this
island since the year 1900.
Women come in and drink our wine.
When we are rested,
they come into our room and take our,"
and I said, "My life
is the same as yours."
I said, "Let's start yelling,"
and they all left the room.
And I went to a bathroom
and I laid on my back, and it was chilly,
and I knew I made a restaurant
with automatic dispenser.
And he stuck his cock so far down my mouth
that I knew it was a broom being handled.
I said, "You can't wait
to get ahold of my leg."
I said, "These floors have
leaves on them, these are shoes.
These are shoes that you're sweeping up."
- [Mark] Evelyn?
- Yeah?
- [Mark] Do you remember your family?
- Yes, I do.
All three brothers and six sisters.
They hadn't graduated.
I'm using up my college
education right now,
but I remember Hunter, my French classes,
learning that it was just a cigarette.
That, yes, you could make
a country with a cigarette.
That your eyes would become
dull to them after your fifth inhalation.
That's 52 strokes from a machine gun.
- [Mark] Evelyn, when's the last time
you saw any members of your family?
- 18 years ago, one day
before the stroke of midnight.
That's when the glass grows
12 feet high, at midnight.
So I wasn't falling asleep
and I said, "So, so, so."
And I said, "Stephen King is your father,"
and I got back to the brick wall
and I still hadn't had a drink,
it's going on 33 hours now,
and I faint and I get
down humbly, like this,
and I said, "Lord, why have
you forsaken this child?"
And he looked out and I could see
lottery tickets falling to the ground.
And she says, "Oh."
And I knew that she, the white girl,
was just as violent as the black men.
And there were a group of men behind
and they said, "Get away from her,"
and they followed me down the street
and knocked me in the back of my balls.
And I said, "Do you wanna have sex?"
And he came, I always do,
because I don't have a
racial bone in my body.
I love black girls for their early youth.
You know, they are backpacks.
Those backpacks do have words in them,
like I need a little breath of fresh air,
or don't take that, I saw that already.
Then you walk out, I put a backpack down.